all right it's the last talk of the day
you guys made it and you know the first
thing I want to do is to thank the MCS
and the organizers for having such a
great conference so give them a round of
applause all right now I'm gonna ask
something of you everyone in this room
I'd appreciate it if you'd take your
phones out and hold them in your hands
you can do it okay everybody pretty much
okay now pass your phone to the person
on your right
okay look at that phone feel it
recognize it but you almost can't do
that right because you're so distracted
thinking about your phone in someone
else's hands oh it's awful it's just
awful and the thing that I want to bring
up here is that the reason that we feel
this way is that our phones are now an
extension of ourselves these phones are
become who we are in our connection to
that data
Pete smart makes this point when he
talks about designing for human-computer
interaction which we're gonna talk a
little about a little bit today when he
talks about our relationship with
technology but we're gonna talk about it
with a different stint we're not gonna
talk about the device itself but how we
relate to these technological advances
so you can you can pass the phones back
you know all right so there are a lot of
different takes about living our lives
increasingly online and if you're in
this room chances are as we started to
adopt things digitally you got excited
we were thinking about all the things
that we could build all the things that
we can make and curiosity for how we
could represent ourselves online so
first we have geo cities which is like a
bastion of Internet explosion I mean I
can't make something that's good nobody
can like that that's just it we reached
the pinnacle right at the beginning then
we in myspace which a lot of people
customized everyone was friends with Tom
and actually in putting this talk
together I revisited mine which was a
time capsule two terrible bangs weird
old art pictures and weird pictures of
me in a bathroom I don't know it was a
face some people might have started
developing with Dragon Ball Z and some
people started because they wanted to be
leet hackers so good at programming that
their fingers were literally on fire
whatever our interests were the Internet
allowed us to explore and share our
lives and express ourselves in creative
bizarre interesting
and unique ways that only a collectivity
of humans could possibly imagine but the
only constant is change and soon we had
so many ways of being represented online
and so many people were online that we
needed to automate these tasks we needed
something that could analyze build
manage and sort for us and as things
become more complicated what we realize
is all of our lives become summations of
these digital models we become pieces of
someone else's algorithms which means we
could be summarized in a single way so
people are starting to use search
engines rather than libraries or
teachers to make sense of the world
we're inhabiting these inaccuracies
start to be reflected in what we learn
what we believe in they become our
societies and our education and tech can
be super magical in this way right
that's such a cool thing that we can all
be here together for the same reason in
Iceland but just like any other software
we write the more magic it contains the
more it can fail I'm Sara Dresner known
on Twitter as Sara IDO and I work for
Microsoft yeah and today's talk is
called live and machine learning so in
this talk we're gonna explore the
paradigm shift that machine learning
brings and we're gonna do that through
talking about how much you need learnt
machine learning works at a really high
level we don't have a ton of time to go
into it but we're also going to talk
about challenges to democracy through
image machine learning we're also gonna
talk about machine learning for good
machine learning does a lot of really
cool things and we're gonna talk about
those two and then we're also gonna talk
about some of the practical tech that we
all know so not necessarily machine
learning but how we can make a
difference with some of the things that
we know today so let's talk at a very
high level about what machine learning
is and we'll kick it off with a quote by
the fella who coined the term machine
learning gives computers the ability to
learn without being explicitly
programmed
okay so we're programmers we're familiar
with if-then statements so what if these
come
Editions for the if-then statements
become complex I mean really complex if
you're building a program to understand
that this is a pug and this is a kitten
you don't necessarily want to program an
if-statement for every single pixel here
or the possibility for every pixel for
every single pug photo I mean that's not
how our brains work right so how do you
program it well you want to teach it a
certain pug leanness you want your
teacher to let you you want your model
to learn the essence of the Pug so in
truth there are a few ways of doing this
sometimes like the example above we can
tag a set of data and your model will
use this supervised data set to
distinguish between these classes and
this will help it learn better this is
called supervised machine learning but
there are other times where we don't
really know the answer so if I asked a
computer what those pugs would look like
if they were bred together with
stegosauruses well that's not really a
thing so there's nothing we can check
against and that's when we'll use an
unsupervised process but let's dive into
supervised process because it's the
easiest to explain and the time we have
and it's also pretty common and in truth
even within supervised machine learning
there are thousands of algorithms that
you could use and among those
convolutional neural networks are
probably the most popular but genetic is
the easiest to understand so we're gonna
use that to kind of discuss things on a
high level today so let's explore a
simple toy model in order to make a pug
kitten sorter what we do is build an
algorithm that builds algorithms and
we'll build many of these and they'll do
their best to sort these and do their
best sorting and at first it will be bad
at it they won't just be bad at it
they'll be terrible but we have another
function that will check this and
they'll check it against that tag data
and for every kitten in pug scenario so
the ones that get it wrong are thrown
away and the ones that get it right
circle back to the Builder and then the
Builder starts using those to create new
builders now this might seem hacky and
imperfect and that's because it is if we
did this one
twice or three times it would fail but
we do it thousands of times and we don't
do it for a small amount of conditions
either we build up all of the gradients
that make up an eye and then we match it
up against all of the other eyes that we
know of and then we match that against
the likelihood of snouts and in fact our
own classification system genus kingdom
phylum is a really human comprehensible
version composed of this kind of set of
rules so the part I want you to remember
is this moving forward the point where
we check you can see how that's a very
important part of this we have to check
if we want to get the data right and we
must do so and keep on checking and
another really important part here is if
I only gave these pug pictures that it
was fed on I mean that would be correct
right these are all pugs but what would
what might happen is it might fail when
it's trying to find our one true pug so
the type of data that we train on is
really vital to whether or not we have
an accurate model okay
so let's explore some ways that machine
learning has failed but I'm gonna call
this section the road to hell is paved
with good intentions because none of
what I'm showing you here today is made
with the idea of corrupting society
quite the opposite all of these are
really and well intentioned examples but
their failure is really good for us to
explore so that we don't fail in the
future so let's say you need to patrol a
city but you don't have enough patrol
units to completely cover the city so it
might make sense to figure out where all
the crime is happening and just have
some patrol units that focus on the
areas of most activity but the problem
is not all crime is equal to get enough
data you have to include nuisance crimes
in which no one's hurt like homelessness
or panhandling with the violent crimes
like rape and murder but rape and murder
don't tend to be clustered in this way
it takes a lot more data to build an
area which is why the nuisance data is
included so on another issue is that
those nuisance data areas those tend to
be the poorer areas so what ends up
happening is you get more patrol areas
in the poorer areas and then we have
more
data on those patrol areas and we get
into this weird feedback loop where
we're just patrolling those and then the
rapes and murders that happen in the
affluent areas start to not be reported
and this is what saw the software pred
pull does that we use in the United
States and it's an example of sample
bias and machine learning so another
issue with this that the US Department
of Education has found is that once
you're a criminal
sorry once you're a criminal you're
pretty likely to become a criminal again
a lot of people keep reoffending and
what they found was the reason why
people do this is that they report that
they find it really hard to fit back
into society once that once they're in
jail another thing is that employment
becomes more difficult because you have
to disclose that you were once in jail
on your employment forms and then people
are less likely to employ you but here's
an important part employment tends to be
the number one indicator of whether
you're gonna end up back in prison and
even the analysis of who ends up in the
system uses machine learning so when
most defendants are booked in jail in
jail they respond to a coppiced
questionnaire and this is fed into a
system that defines the risk level for
that's used in the length of their
sentencing so whether you're in for a
short amount of time or a long amount of
time in an evaluation of more than
10,000 of these people found that the
risk scores showed a startling
difference black defendants had scores
pretty evenly matched across the board
one meaning no risk 10 would have have a
very long sentence whereas the white
risk assessments look quite different
many are assessed at one steadily degree
decreasing - very few at ten now you
might say well what's what if that's
just valid data except upon analysis
it's not really the study showed that
blacks were twice as likely to be
labeled higher risk and not reoffended
white counterparts were labeled not as
risky as they were so if we look at this
in human terms we see James reveille
with low risk at three Robert cannon
with medium risk at six
James reveille had a domestic violence
aggravated assault grand theft petty
theft drug trafficking and he
subsequently did
and Robert cannon had one petty theft
there are more - Gregory Lugo low risk
at one Mallory Williams medium risk at
six
Gregory Lugo had three duis one battery
and subsequently reoffended Mallory
Williams had two misdemeanors and never
reoffended again and these are just a
couple of them there's a lot these kind
of algorithms don't just affect black
people either Zilly is a construction
worker who stole a piece of equipment
and sold it for parts because he was low
on cash since then he's been going to
church he's been volunteering but he
says that his risk score doesn't reflect
any of the ways that he's bettering
himself as a person therefore not really
a good indicator of whether or not he's
going to reoffending n so what makes
coppice fail as a machine learning
algorithm one thing is that it has no
transparency you basically make the
algorithm and then they are sending it
out so basically the people who are
using it don't know how it works
another thing is because of this because
of that relationship it doesn't adapt
over time remember we talked about how
important that step of adapting is and
related to these things people use it
without any questions another question
that might be asked at this time is
whether this is a good place for machine
learning algorithms machine learning
algorithms are super powerful and really
wonderful but sometimes this should be
in the hands of a judge and here's the
main thing about machine learning
algorithms we try to be predictive of
the future but machine learning
algorithms can really only evaluate the
past so Brennan one of the co-creators
of this technology didn't actually build
the technology with the idea of the use
for sentencing but that's the strange
thing about some of this tech once you
put it out in the world adoption can be
beyond us anyone who maintains an
open-source project will say that
sometimes you put something out in the
world and the way people use it is
totally different than the way that you
intended or the way that you had
foreseen this is why it's critical for
these types of technologies to be
transparent in order to not be abused
they can't be magical people will say
algorithms can't be biased
but algorithms are written by people so
this doesn't always happen to criminal
only happen to criminals it happens to
us too
machine learning is now incorporated
into a lot of the tools that we use
every day and a lot of our Internet
experience is built off of machine
learning algorithms so axiom a data
brokerage had an average of 1,500 data
points for 500 million consumers
including the entire adult population of
the United States that was in 2012 and
that's just one company so using a
Chrome extension called what Facebook
thinks you like I could find some of the
ways that the systems had tagged me so
some of these are pretty obvious if you
follow me on Twitter you probably know
some of these things like software
developer I'm into cloud computing I
like dogs like wine to strange and like
kind of false so mermaid I don't know
trenchcoats I've never read a James
Patterson book
I don't knit and it even got my
political proclivities wrong so the
issue with this is Facebook uses these
types of tags to drive directed ads and
you can see you that you can use these
ads to target on different demographics
including race and a couple years ago
people could show you different houses
that you could buy depending on these
demographics depending on race this is
illegal under the Fair Housing Act of
1968 but here's the thing
once that was pointed out to Facebook
they fixed it and this is a major theme
here it's not to make software that
never fails that's impossible every
machine learning algorithm can have a
failure but once it does fail you have
to course-correct
and change things and another problem
with this that you might have already
thought about is that you don't tell
Facebook your race their targeting based
on ethnic affinity which is used by the
same algorithm that thinks I'm into
mermaids so I'm not coming down on
Facebook in particular this is a problem
with all machine learning algorithms
used by every company so this the issue
with this
and what you might have guessed is that
everything that you're seeing is
filtered and that filtration system can
be fallible at best and illegal at worse
it might not mean houses it can also
mean that the things and the studies
that you're seeing and educational
material that you're seeing is based on
what you already believe which like that
patrolling system that we saw earlier
becomes a self-reinforcing prophecy and
I've also personally seen this I worked
at one point I work for a company that
was starting to use machine learning
they proposed an idea to surface content
based on demographics I had just
happened to read up on that issue this
that weekend mainly that it wasn't legal
and I brought it up to people and they
said oh yeah that you're right this
could probably and introduce bias so we
didn't ship that feature but here's an
important part I was just a regular
engineer on that project I wasn't a data
scientist and I wasn't a PM I wasn't the
person shaping that project I was just
carrying things out but without raising
my hand we might have shipped that
feature to some really bad consequences
it's not that digitizing the world is
inherently bad but the more technology
becomes embedded in all aspects of life
it matters whether the technology is
biased alienating or harmful and these
tales are pretty dark but machine
learning offers us a lot of amazing
benefits as well as my brilliant
co-worker Paige Bailey says it's like
the risk that we take every time we get
into cars or airplanes they've
completely transformed every aspect of
life and made things possible that
wouldn't be possible before they're
inherently dangerous and they can be
seriously misused so think about it I
mean I wouldn't be on this stage if it
wasn't for airplanes and some of you
wouldn't be here right all in the same
room that's pretty amazing
but people have used airplanes as
weapons and so we have a certain respect
for them okay now that I've bummed
everyone out let's explore some of the
wonderful applications for machine
learning and what we can do with it
okay as I mentioned I work for Microsoft
and an azure we have a thing called
cognitive services there's a specific
API called the mote emotion API and what
it allow us to do is analyze things like
pictures and videos and see what emotion
it
Tech's from what the computer sees it
can use to be used to make things like
this which I built in three Jas which
has no practical application except
entertaining my four-year-old
stepdaughter Wow yeah there's stuff up
there huh
okay which can also be pretty magical to
tell you the truth but what if we put
this to more useful use okay so I was
mentoring a blind woman and she
mentioned to me that she felt left out
of a lot of conversations on Twitter
because a lot of the photos didn't have
alt text and this is true for her even
on things like news sites so I made I
used another cognitive services offering
the computer vision API which will not
only analyze photo but also its contents
like words and just to show how some of
this works we're gonna dive briefly into
some of the code so we'll get the image
from the user I'm using view jeaious
here these are methods and we're gonna
store it then you can see here we're
using Axios for a simple call to the
computer vision API and then we're
you're gonna use address cognitive
services to analyze that image and we'll
do so in a couple of different ways one
to see what the image contains and one
to check for text within the image then
we'll dynamically add the alt text to
the image and now that this is built I'm
building a Chrome extension so that
blind people can use it on any website
that they can visit visit so this
application of machine learning can help
bring more people into the conversation
and broaden our reach it's not perfect
but it's headed in a really good
direction where all of a sudden people
who are left out of the story can now be
part of it and that's the amazing thing
that by being inclusive you're actually
meeting business goals it doesn't mean
you're excluding the people in the
center it means that you're reaching a
larger audience there are all sorts of
ways that other people can use machine
learning in medicine too so one of these
is Sophia genetics is training
algorithms to diagnose diseases through
DNA analysis another one that's kind of
dear to my heart
is that all for cure is a social network
for cancer patients where patients can
enter diagnosis and treatment so that
can be analyzed this is really important
because doctors can't just report every
single patient that they have and they
can't read every single study either so
if you have all of these people
reporting what treatments they were used
whether or not they're surviving well
then all of a sudden this machine
learning can pick up all of that data
and we we can become much smarter in
finding cures for cancer health map
algorithm spotted in an Ebola outbreak
nine days before the World Health
Organization and this is a really
important one so I'm just gonna focus on
for just a second nine days is an
incredible amount of lead time for on an
outbreak outbreaks grow exponentially so
by using machine learning we adjusted
the amount of people infected from here
to here that's amazing so you might be
saying to yourself this is all well and
good but I'm not a data scientist and I
don't work with machine learning but
that's okay this subject that about how
technology can shape our lives is really
broad and it doesn't necessarily have to
be machine learning so let's talk about
some of the things that we as web
developers can do now today with what we
already know we work every day on
building applications for so many
different use cases so what if we take
some of the more generic tools that we
have and put them to tasks where we can
maybe help save lives so there's a
firehouse near where I live and they
have some sufficiently complex systems
to make sure that everything is online
and functioning I went out to their
station and I asked them a few questions
about how everything works and to see if
there was anything that I could do that
I might help that might help and here's
what I learned when the truck goes out
it has to communicate with a dispatcher
which will help facilitate if they need
more water supplies or backup and the
app is really simple kind of
purposefully so because they want
everybody able to be able to use it
quickly at a glance and there aren't
that many things that they might need so
for their use case what they created is
really perfect but I asked a few
questions including what happens if
they're all of a sudden offline what if
they can can't communicate well right
now there
get it host fireman okay anyway terrible
joke okay so here's our opportunity what
I created was a really simplified
version of their app preserving the
basic layout but I made use of service
workers and background sync to alert
them when they're offline when they're
offline cue the messages and when it's
backup send them out even if the browser
tab is closed even if something happens
so here's what the application looks
like if we click on water it register if
the sink is registered and it sends it
out but if we go off Wi-Fi then it'll
tell them that they're off offline and
then I could even close out that browser
tab go back and then we can turn the
Wi-Fi back on and then the sync is
registered and what we requested before
is then sent out so the first thing that
we're going to do is alert them one that
when they're offline we're gonna do that
with navigator dot online and we're
ready we're gonna register the service
worker when a request is made the
service worker isn't just a normal
function if you can't just add it as a
method in your app it has to be in a
different JavaScript file and this
details really important if you want to
integrate it so one thing about this is
that you're kind of throwing it over the
wall it's almost like communicating with
a server so you're throwing things at it
and it's throwing things back so we're
gonna pass in the type of event that was
triggered so we can submit or queue what
the user requested not shown here we'll
do some error handling and then after
we've activated and installed the
Service Worker we're gonna strip out the
type from the event tag and pass it into
a function that will process a fetch
request when it gets connectivity in
that function will fetch our URL which
is a placeholder server in this case and
we'll check if the response has happened
and once it has we'll send a message
back to the client with post message so
we'll send the we'll send the response
and the type of resource that was
requested and after that we can alert
the user when it's finally sent but the
most important part of the demo isn't
the service workers it's where we
started we started by asking questions I
went to the firehouse and I asked them
questions
and there are a lot of times where I
wasn't even sure if I could really help
them but by asking questions about what
happened in any kind of use case in any
kind of scenario I can't I finally found
something that they could use the help
for we have to ask questions we have to
ask questions in the beginning like the
fire fire house demo and we have to ask
questions like when it's deployed like
the criminal scores we have to keep
evaluating these systems and where
they're going and make purposeful
decisions to help people in
course-correct when we don't I see a lot
of tech that ask questions about how we
can make our lives more comfortable
which I appreciate I make apps on the
weekends this is a cocktail finder I
built that just finds me cocktails okay
but it seems to me that a
disproportionate amount of projects
focus inward rather than outward focus
on serving people with money instead of
asking people if they need help there
are a lot of opportunities out there to
help and you might already have the
skills to do so it just takes a little
bit of imagination and exploration and
it can really pay off so what I want you
to think about going forward is this but
I truly believe that you're some of the
brightest minds of our generation as you
move forward building applications for
the webs the web you're building the
pillars and blocks that our society
rests on you're crafting the shape of
our digital lives
this could mean building new features
this could mean advocating for
accessibility and this could be as
simple as raising your hand when you
think something isn't right it's not
just your job to create these things and
do as you're told it's also your job to
ask are we building things correctly are
we building the right things and are we
building them well for all of the
digital lives that we touch thank you
you